It turns out the actual implementation is really minimal
compared to what you already implemented.
With this modification you've implemented A-Star,
which is one of the most powerful search algorithms that they use for the present day
to drive self-driving cars through unstructured environments.
The very first thing we do is we expand elements in the open list
to not just contain g as before but also f.
I also included h over here.
That isn't necessary, but I did it anyhow.
So now we have five tubelet's where g is defined as before.
H is the heuristic value of the cell x y, and f is the sum of the two.
The reason why I put f left is I need this for my sort trick
so that I can sort according to f when I sort the list.
So notice this has become two elements longer,
and by moving f to the left side I've implemented that the element I remove
will be the one with the lowest f-value not the lowest g-value.
As I go further down and expand the node as happened in these lines over here,
I now need to modify the index into the next structure a little bit.
X is now element number three, which is technically the fourth element in the list
when we start indexing with zero.
Y is element number four.
G is element number one.
F and h, I don't need to pop here because I compute them from scratch in just a minute.
So as I go further down where I expand a node from the list
and compute of all possible actions what the successive state is
and test whether these are legal states to expand.
I now, as before, increment g by the cross function but here two new lines of code.
First I compute the heuristic function for the new expanded node.
That's very straight forward.
I call it the h2.
Then the next line of code I compute the new sum of the g-value and the h-value.
I use those five things: the new f-value, the new g-value, the new h-value,
and the x and y of the expanded nodes to append to the open list.
So new here is most importantly the f-value but also the h-value.
That's all there is to implementing A-star.
So all I've done is I've just changed the logic according to which
I remove nodes from the stack to pick the one that has the minimum f-value
as opposed to the minimum g-value, and I have A-star.
So let me run it.
This is for the maze we looked at before.
Let me move the open spot to the top over here and put a wall back here.
It turns in this case A-star is not so efficient
and the area over here it has no preference to go either way.
It will finally find the go node.
That, however, changes when I put a big obstacle horizontally over here,
at which point it's really interesting to see A-star cannot decide whether
the horizontal path is best or the vertical path.
So it alternately pops nodes from either one of those.
The moment its over here the same trick applies as before.
It doesn't expand anything in the center anymore
and goes straight to the goal and reaches the goal over here.
That would not happen without A-star.
In fact, the way to rework back to the old search
is to give it an empty heuristic function.
So here is a definition of the heuristic function initializes h always zero everywhere
instead of the heuristic function over here, which I won't use for a second
and just call it heuristic old, and this is the current heuristic function.
If I run it with a heuristic function of all zeros I get back my original search algorithm.
You can see this search algorithm explores into the interior a little bit,
and the result expands more nodes than the A-star.
This might look very insignificant, but if you get to very large environments,
it can make a huge difference especially if there is a huge dead end somewhere
that can't reach the goal.
Then A-star performs much, much more efficiently than the simple search.